ich wollte eigentlich nach tschernobyl
aber das war mir zu luftig stattdessen
stehe ich heute auge in auge mit einer
der gefährlichsten erfindungen die die
menschheit je gemacht hat
nein ich rede nicht von e scootern ich
rede von windrädern thüringer land cdu
windkraft forum gekommen sind vor allem
klimaleugner und windkraft gegner also
ein abend voller möglichkeiten
wir müssen ja wenn wir in deutschland
auf 100 prozent erneuerbare energien
kommen dann haben wir die solar- und
windenergie das ist doch vorgegeben
worden dass meint also machen will
es gibt eine ganze reihe anderer
möglichkeiten klären sie mich auf leere
sie ja ich sage nur es gibt eine ganze
reihe von möglichkeiten die man mit dem
mann als sie das arbeiten kann also es
gibt eine reihe von möglichkeiten die
wollen sie jetzt aber nicht nennen
saison
da sollte sich die politik mal ein
beispiel es gibt eine reihe von
möglichkeiten die nennen wir jetzt aber
nicht
aber es gibt eine reihe frei es gibt
einige möglichkeiten das noch anders zu
sein natürlich kein windrad bauen und
dafür andere energieformen welche zum
beispiel und die gefahren die durch
atomkraft ausgeht stichwort fukushima
ich weiß nicht wo der reflexe meyer
kommt dass wenn neue atom oder reaktor
hören dass er sofort ablehnen und
herrscht ternopil ist ein schlechtes
beispiel
da wollte einer der experten den
klimawandel und das hat natürlich kritik
ach nee applaus sie haben gerade auf der
bühne den menschengemachten klimawandel
ignoriert der menschgemachte klima des
höchstwahrscheinlich da steht nicht der
erste wiesn 99,7 prozent aller
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus aller
klimawissenschaftler wird er wird das
wird das status weltwirtschaft bewiesen
wie viele wissenschaftler davon ausgehen
glauben sie an den menschengemachten
klimawandel
ich glaube daran dass es der mensch eine
aufgabe hat die klimaziele einzuhalten
und dafür müssen unseren beitrag leisten
sie ja den menschengemachten klimawandel
ich glaube daran dass die leute die
sorgen haben vor dem klimapolitischen
wirkung dass die nicht unberechtigt
sinne dass die politik verpflichtet ist
was zu machen wird die politik nicht
wahr dafür angekreidet dass sie auf
einfache fragen die ich einfach
antwortet so eine diskussion lebt von
dem spektrum wort und wieder wort und
meinungsaustausch auch mit dem publikum
wenn sie zu einer podiumsdiskussion mit
experten geben dann sind sie als bürger
erstmal nicht so informiert wie die
experten da meisten die experten ja auch
experten darum lasst man sich ja dann
auch von den experten beeinflussen
deswegen fährt nicht gut wenn die
experten auch experten werden und ich
leute die meinungen haben und nicht auf
fakten basierende argumentieren
das ist wie beim zdf gibt experten die
ihre eigene meinung sagte und die nicht
immer die meinung der fernsehzuschauer
ist trotzdem senden sie diese anderen
kommentar ein kritikpunkt an windrädern
ist ja dass zum beispiel der rotmilan
und auch andere vögel an den windrädern
zerschreddern welche alle vögel insekten
hat er alles so schreibt und das gar
nicht nachvollziehen 100.000 im jahr
aber nur mal zum vergleich es sterben 18
millionen vögel jährlich an glasscheiben
in deutschland also es ist ja so wie
jedes jahr so wie wenn sie mehrere
affären hätten und ihre frau verlässt
sie daten weil sie mal porto
man kann das jetzt als vergleich setzen
es geht ja nicht bloß um saison mit
klimaleugner und windkraft gegnern hilft
nur eins upforce windrad ohren zu und
den infraschall genießen herrlich für
weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße